these kind of personal things but today
I need to make an exception seeing that
some of the major influences of our time
have been de-platformed they never gave
me grounds they never sent me an
official email they never gave me an
official reason they just delete your
profile and uh you just can't log in
anymore sometimes I think I think to
myself what if the southern I'm leaving
behind what if the content that I'm
leaving behind were to be removed
through one of these decision makers at
the top that I do Platform and then it
hit me that one time they could just
decide to remove everything that we've
done online
with one decision now to be honest one
of the most impactful Islamic
initiatives that I'm leaving behind
although we're leaving behind is the
establishment of the helping of the
establishment of the first of the sky
and Masjid endow Center in the
Scandinavian region Islam Nets which is
in charge of this project is bringing
the tower the fight against islamophobia
and the Masjid institution itself to new
heights I mean I think that this is an
initiative we all need to be part of it
leaves behind a physical asset that we
can leave for our children and our great
grandchildren I think you and I need to
invest in this Ramadan Allah says in the
Quran
um
by no means shall you attain Alber
Paradise unless you spend in Allah's
cause of that which you love and
wherever of good you spend Allah knows
it well so click the link to donate and
do not miss out on this rare opportunity
to send forth for your the numerous Good
Deeds that will be performed in this
mission that you can imagine will be
asada kajaria for you and for me and for
all of us